carlos carrasco
starting for the mets tonight carrasco
ready to go miguel rojas digs in and
it's time for baseball
yeah it is
first pitch of the game of fly ball deep
left goodbye home run for miguel rojas
something about that first inning you
said hey guys got her vulnerability i
think miguel rojas heard the scouting
report himself in new york he knew
don't waste any time it's
a tough inning for carrasco and rojas
makes him pay
goes up gets that one and sends it
toward right center field
nimmo will cut it off but jazz hustling
all the way to second and he's not done
ball kicked around a little bit in
center field and jazz is on his way to
third
now the marlins have come out tonight
ready to play some baseball i love it
leading rbi man nobody out runner at
third marlins already up one nothing
ground ball base hit he'll add another
ribby
jazz comes in to score and the marlins
take a two to nothing lead hal aguilar
probably starting to heat up just a bit
and brinson pops one up see if it's
playable vr with the wind carrying it
toward the stands reaches and makes the
catch
nicely done
vr went as far as he could and plucked
it right before it would have landed in
the photo box
o2 coming fastball struck him out
and so carrasco takes care of diaz to
end the inning his first strikeout for
the marlins it is sandy alcatra 28th
start of the year jonathan vr two for
seven in this series including a home
run
and he drives this one and this is gonna
go out of the ballpark a long home run
for vr
he breached one
rojas homers on the first pitch and now
vr does the same and it's 2-1
number 17 for vr and he clouded it
well that'll send our statistics people
scrambling when was the last time he had
a game where each team's lead-off hitter
hit the first pitch
out of the ballpark
on 1-2 alonso lays off a change-up and
oh he went around they ask at first base
and carlos torres said he offered that
he did what he said he chased that was a
change up in the dirt it was away but
alonso couldn't quite lay off
el faro hole for five in this series and
he swings at the first pitch and tops
one to lindor has to hurry against
alfaro and pete digs it out alfaro one
of the fastest catchers in the game got
down the line in a hurry but lindor got
him for the first down
curveball from carrasco gets alcantara
looking
and hitters were struggling
broken bat and jazz is able to get to it
sliding to make the play in shallow
right field to take it away from javier
baez
now the athleticism has been on display
with the bat first from jazz and well
how about a little leather
and mazika line drive caught by aguilar
i'll tell you what that's gonna be three
innings in a row holly where i got a
little star next to some play behind
sandy
well aguilar a little tip to the crowd i
love it
and goes back to it on 3-2 gets the
strikeout his third 2-1 marlin
and he strikes out sanchez went to the
change-up on three and two he's got his
third strikeout and he's retired 10 in a
row
chomped over the mound this time ladoor
has to charge against diaz and throws
him out beautifully done
to retire the side that's 12 straight
for carrasco
throws a breaking ball that's nubbed
down to third tough play for diaz and
nemo beats it out and it gets on by and
nimble will go to second just a little
end of the bad number
and diaz threw it away
nemo with an infield hit francisco
lindor will step in with a tying run now
at second base and nimo and he hits it
out to left field hit pretty well nila
cruz going back it's over his head and
off the base of the wall that'll bring
in nemo with the tying one lindor stands
at second with an rbi double and it's
two to two lined out to left field his
first time up tonight so he's starting
to use the whole field
so that's a ball
he can't fake the third anymore
you can fake to third
but you can't then throw to an
unoccupied base which is what he did and
that's a block and for the second time
on this home stand lindor causes a block
that allows him to score a run well he
originally was faking and then he threw
it when he realized his error
and he gets conforted to chase the
change-up
strikeout number four for sandy and
there are two ways
there goes el faro fly ball hit to right
might have a chance for a double play if
conforto hurries and he will get him
running on the pitch and he's doubled
off
for the 9-3 double play alcatra was
caught looking his first time up and he
goes down swinging this time four
strikeouts now for carrasco he gets
around the error
zika hits one over the back that's a
fair ball hits off the sidewall
they'll get two bases out of this
as sanchez retrieves mazeka ripping a
double
and he just freezes vr
looking for something else another
strikeout for sandy's got five through
five
rojas a little tapper in front of the
mound carrasco has it low throw gets by
alonso
and rojas will get to second base to
start the sixth inning tying run is in
scoring position three balls no strikes
on aguilar
that one kicks away but rojas will stay
put
first and second now and that'll bring
up jesus sanchez well last time luke was
in the game he came in in the fifth
inning he'll need some magic here again
tonight in the sixth payoff pitch from
loop on the way is low for ball four
that's a great at-bat for jesus sanchez
and the bases are loaded for louis
princeton 3-2 pitch is low and in
that'll tie the game
rojas will score to make it 3-3
and that's three consecutive walks won
by carrasco and two by loop
one-two coming
grounded vr gonna go to first
side retire marlins get even on a bases
loaded walk luff gets two big outs now
looking to shut it down and keep it tied
0-2 to alonso
who rips one into left field for a base
hit that'll beat de la cruz and go to
the wall
and alonso's got himself a two out
double 02 slider and pete got on it for
his 19th double of the year
conforto lifts one into left field
de la cruz coming in dealing with that
win makes the play and the inning is
over sandy gets through six and keeps it
a tie game 3-3
there's a swing and a miss he got biased
to chase a change up down and away
and jeff loops wanted to center field
that's down for a base hit
so another 02 hit alonso had one in the
last inning on a slider this time mcneal
on a changeup and the mets of the go
ahead run aboard with one out
and mazeka rips one to right field for a
base hit
and it's booted by sanchez and mcneil
goes to third
mazika with three bullets tonight he's
two for three suddenly have an
opportunity to take the lead here in the
bottom of the seventh inning
that's pulled off the glove of agaloi
that's a fair ball in comes mcneal with
a tying run but zika around second he's
going to try for third sanchez's throw
to third is not in time
the mets have taken the lead
tom smith with a bullet off aguilar's
glove from the go ahead hit and it's
four to three new york four to three new
york mets trying for their fourth or
fifth straight win depending on how you
look at it and then when diaz will try
and nail it down marlins are down to
their final strike 3-2 from diaz he
struck him out and the ball game is over
edwin diaz with the save puts on the
finishing touches as the mets complete a
sweep of the marlins dom smith with the
go ahead pinch hit in the seventh and
the mets have won either four or five in
a row any way you slice it they're just
a game under 500.